I saw you I don't see anybody and
apparently no one's anxious to see me
but Memorial Day weekend I was hanging
out on the beach with my family and I
see you and your face I know I have to
apologize because we were supposed to
come over for s'mores and and then I had
he had this whole we supposed to not
talk about the fires on the beach we
don't do fires on the beach yeah but
there was that no it's they said it was
okay okay I had but they said that my
kids want to do s'mores and the
neighbors were you know starting these a
little bonfires on the beach if you're
real careful and they say it's because
all this wood is washed up on it so I
was like yeah that's a good idea and
they feel like a real I felt like yeah
I'm a real dad I'm doing like violator
for the other kids like wanted yeah man
fire yeah go yeah yeah in seconds I was
on fire like spinning around it was a
disaster I wanted to come over for the
s'mores in the head of leave town on a
family emergency and so I didn't get to
come for this more do you do anything
special with the s'mores or is it just
like a standard s'more I don't like this
to see I don't like s'mores myself my
kids loved him I never got it even back
in the days when I was going camping and
if you're like doing it right hi
Charlotte
chocolate marshmallow broccoli where's
the recipe no no I I never really went
for it I like the I just don't a big
like gooey marshmallow fan but my kids
go crazy for it so I help them make them
and then I don't do are you into that
kind of stuff I love it yeah we actually
ended up doing s'mores earlier in the
day not knowing you were doing s'mores
later I was gonna double s'more yeah I
was gonna s'more and that's four more
times dirty it sounds dirty
amazing at the beach I mean I see you
down there and you're like a piece of
paper lit on fire
you're just like not so funny I don't
it's so funny as people were shocked to
see me at the beach I don't look cool I
see you you look this guy looks amazing
everywhere and you're walking along they
got your baseball cap on you're looking
cool on the beach and I'm like I'm that
I try to you came out like he came out
like he was gonna rescue me off the sand
and I'm also a shocking white a shocking
white no it's a piece of paper lit on
fire going across then somebody just
stumbling along it's like the flash yeah
yeah
you